we're in a world that's convinced that
the truth must be simple and all of
these simple truths don't survive
the collider that is modern social media
so I don't disagree the problem with a
truth which is boundlessly complex is
that functionally it's useless so that's
what and I'm so glad you made this point
that's the puzzle
we're now in a world where to do the
Nuance is to get yourself Tangled
Because the Internet is not friendly to
Nuance on the other hand to say
something simply and crisply
leads you into
disappointing everyone who's believed in
you and you know we were talking before
a little bit about Christopher Hitchens
yes tell me about your thoughts on hitch
I asked Sam this question some spent a
good bit of time with him what would the
modern culture be like if hitch was
still alive
hitch I think would have been forced to
either self-incinerate
or
adapt
and I'm not sure what you would have
done what self-incineration in this
context
one of the things that makes Christopher
Hitchens a hero to so many people almost
oddly a secular Saint if you will is
that he held the promise that one could
simply
stand
in some place that was reasonable
and hold forth from that simple
perspective like yep
there's nothing to Islam it is nonsense
it might be something he would say or
you might say
um
you know free speech is absolute and you
have every right to say anything you
want and I have every right to say and
the better ideas will prevail
now you watch what's happened with Sam
and this question of trump
Sam perceives Trump to be an asymmetric
existential threat
and was willing to go and back the idea
that the hunter Biden laptop story
might not
have benefited the election
and he's lost an enormous number of
people who otherwise agree with him and
now what's the reasoning the reasoning
and something oddly I first time I met
Sam I went on his show to warn him that
you can't just optimize for truth you
have to optimize I said I have four
variables I can't live without truth
meaning Fitness and Grace
so Trump is a fitness puzzle to Sam
which is if we allow Trump to destroy
the country in Sam's mind then we've
lost Fitness there's no there's no point
in being truthful
and then there's a question about what
is the meaning do you destroy the
meaning of a democracy when you hold
back information maybe you do maybe it
no longer feels like it's an actual
democracy
and what is the graceful thing to do
what is the just and right thing to do
um
I am convinced
that some of hitch's positions
were attractive because he was using his
big brain to suggest that life could be
lived simply
if we were just strong enough of
character if we were clear enough of
thought we could espouse something like
free speech or Reason and it would be
enough
without requiring that we
hold it up to a higher power or that you
know you get caught in some very serious
situation where you're in an edge case
Free Speech does not exist in an
absolute form in under American law
it just doesn't really we we mentioned
um Miller versus California which was a
sort of a follow-on decision to Memoirs
versus Massachusetts
um
you don't have a right
to broadcast pornography because
pornography does not enjoy First
Amendment
uh protection
now how do you discern that pornography
doesn't well the the justices claim that
it doesn't and there's a you know a
three-factor test for what is
pornography
which was I believe attenuated under
something called Memoirs versus
Massachusetts but that was not allowed
to stand you're not allowed to
necessarily endanger troop movements
uh by blabbing information in a war
you're not able to slander a libel there
are all sorts of adjustments to free
speech
and when you when you come at one of
these perspectives from an absolutist
frame of mind
you have to hope that you're not going
to meet the edge case a good example for
me was the Second Amendment
I noticed that many Second Amendment
types took an absolutist perspective
saying the right to keep and bear arms
will not be infringed and don't bother
me about a well-regulated militia I said
okay
I'm not going to talk to you about a
well-regulated militia my question is
should the Davy Crockett be sold at
Kmart and they would often say well
what's the Davy Crockett and I said well
it's about a hundred pound personal nuke
well first of all I was very
flabbergasted that a lot of gun
enthusiasts did not know that there was
a personal nuke developed by the United
States
but then immediately many of them saw
where this was going which is okay if
we're going to restrict personal nukes
at Kmart
then you've got your your foot in the
door the camel has its nose Under the
Tent it's a difference of degree not a
difference of kind all the way down
exactly so I think that personal nukes
have to be sold at Kmart because the
American population needs to keep parity
with the American Military
and then I say well do you realize what
you just said do you realize that you've
bounced out of your very simplified
framework
they don't and this is partially the
problem which is that if you can't talk
about taste
and trade-offs and balance because none
it's all squishy
then you have all of these people
running to these different Ultra
simplifications none of which work
there's a quote from one of my smartest
friends guinda
a dilemma of tweeting is that you're
aware of exceptions and conditions to
your statements but can't include them
without turning an elegant aphorism into
a clunky mess so you must choose between
writing tiniered garbage or getting torn
apart by pedants and replies and quote
tweets
I've chosen to fail in a particular no
but this is this is really important
I'm failing how about you
depends what your goals are well but my
point to you is I don't think we're
meant to succeed here what's that mean
what's the criteria
was that a herd
what's the criteria no sorry the person
who just said window no a guy guy what
he said was
that you're aware of the trade-off then
there's no way out of the trade-off
I believe that there are ways out
but they have their own problems once
you start to understand all of the
different forces that are arrayed
against you
you realize that if somebody chooses to
hyper focus on various things
they can effectively destroy your
credibility in general and you brought
up Wikipedia and I wanted to talk about
that an interesting thing that's
happening with Wikipedia is the
difference between individual Wikipedia
entries
and Wikipedia entries on like a subject
or a plant
or a geographic place
so isn't it strange that if you were to
look up for example
um
pneumatic drill on Wikipedia there would
be a huge technically accurate article
about pneumatic drills what constitutes
it who invented it right
and then you look up Jordan Peterson and
I guarantee you it's going to be a war
zone
and now you've you fuse these two things
together which is weaponized Wikipedia
and
factual Wikipedia
and this is like some really dangerous
new object and I always knew that
Wikipedia The Genius thing that it was
at a finite shelf life because it made
the Fatal flaw of using authoritative
sources as Bedrock truth
what happens when trolls get access to
bedrock sources what happens when the
state department or the Department of
Homeland Security or the intelligence
Community or people who hate you
that was
the headlines that happened after my
episode on Joe's show
were it was the weekend that somebody
had
nudged the definition of recession on
Wikipedia to no longer be two
consecutive quarters of negative GDP
growth
and
this was a Monday and it happened over
the weekend uh
mentioned it and all hell break loose
broke loose it had already broken loose
over the weekend and then obviously
anything touches gets Amplified to right
my Heavens you like
okay so the
the definitions that we use I think
Shapiro calls it semantic overload
uh that's the Battleground ultimately
almost all tell me the frame and I'll
tell you the argument
like somebody will say
um
you know
is it worth stopping Donald Trump by
suppressing stories yes or no go
I was like well
first of all the question was
designed to subsume that we have to stop
Donald Trump
now I might agree that with that I
believe maybe we should stop Donald
Trump but you did make that the argument
and then you piled on a question on top
of it you subsume that within the frame
and so
more or less this is everything at the
moment which is if you can if you can
Define misgendering and dead naming
um you've won the argument I suppose
it's a world in which yeah so I'll give
you an example for the fledgling podcast
is out there when you first start doing
a podcast you're nervous that the guest
doesn't like you you're nervous that the
guest isn't interested in you that your
question sucks that your question
doesn't make sense and you're terrified
of Silence among
millions of other things did any of
those happen in this episode oh you've
been very welcoming how could I not
after you serenaded me with you get a
laylee this episode is brought to you by
a product I've used every single day for
over three years now and that is ag1 ag1
is a foundational nutrition supplement
that covers whole body Health it is a
staple part of my supplement regime I
take the travel packs with me when I'm
on the road like here in LA and it
really does make a massive difference
especially to my digestion if your
energy levels have been all over the
place if you really feel like you need
to make an improvement to your nutrition
this is a fantastic place to start it's
been updated 52 times over the last
decade and only uses the best
ingredients at the highest quality to
make sure that it covers all of your
nutritional bases there is a 90-day
money-back guarantee for 90 days you can
use athletic greens and if you do not
like it or are not satisfied with the
results they'll give you your money back
if you're looking for a simpler
effective investment for your health try
ag1 today by going to drink ag1.com
modern wisdom you'll get videos free
supply of vitamin D five free ag1 travel
packs plus that 90-day money-back
guarantee that's drink ag1.com
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Eric then press here for the full length
three hour episode
go on
press it